violence against journalists is on the
rise and more attacks are threatening
press Freedom across the globe U.N
statistics show at least 74 journalists
have been killed this year alone and
most of the cases go unresolved among
the victims is veteran Al Jazeera
journalist Shireen Abu ackler she was
shot dead by Israeli forces while
covering an Israeli raid in the occupied
West Bank the most dangerous country for
journalists is Mexico at least 18
members of the press have been killed
there this year alone marking a new
record also high on the list Ukraine
Pakistan the Philippines and Brazil
okay joining me now on set is Friday
marrovich he is the executive director
of the international press Institute
Friday thanks so much for being on this
program thank you for having me Al
Jazeera journalist as we've mentioned
she was killed this year along with
dozens of journalists as we've just
heard despite admissions by Israel that
it was most likely Israeli soldiers
there has been no justice for her case
if there's no hope of justice for
Shireen what hope is there for some of
the lesser-known journalists who have
been killed while reporting our
insurance cases particularly appalling
because she was killed in broad daylight
wearing protective gear showing that
she's a member of the press and to your
question in terms of how to ensure
Justice it's to ensure that there is a
continuous campaign just because there
is no justice now that doesn't mean that
there should never be so the campaign
needs to continue from outside Shireen
was named by IPI as the World Press
Freedom hero so an eminent panel of
editors recognize this we will continue
campaigning as well the other Freedom
press Freedom organizations and what we
have seen is that when there are high
profile cases something can get done the
statistics are that only one in nine
cases of killings of journalists to
become resolved by the perpetrator are
convicted but what is important is the
ones that are resolved are usually the
most high profile cases so we have to
continue campaigning we have to continue
bring it on the agenda of those
governments who can do something which
in this case is the Israeli government
but also those governments who are on
the sideline who have Partnerships with
the dead government they should also be
the ones demanding for justice we just
heard from the previous guests about the
power of social media in terms of of
hate speech and misinformation
violence can manifest itself not just in
a physical way but a lot of journalists
are facing violence online as well
absolutely and this is in a way a
precursor to physical violence in many
cases it does two things first of all it
tries to threaten the journalists so
they don't continue doing their work uh
to frighten them into giving up the
journalist work but second of all it
creates an atmosphere of impunity and
this is even more appalling when it's
done by political leaders it does create
an atmosphere of enabling those people
who might actually take
violence into their hands and do
something physical against those
journalists it makes them feel empowered
and enabled this is an appalling Trend
that we have seen on a political level
in many many countries in democracies as
well as those countries which are not
democracies and this is something that
needs to be attacked and this is
something that needs to be eliminated
what we have also seen is threats
against female journalists which are
particularly
poignant what we have seen is that
female journalists are most often
targeted than their male counterparts
and then above the police but we've just
run short of time I'm sorry Friday but
we really appreciate appreciate your
time on this issue it's an important one
to raise awareness of franet Maravich
the executive director of the
international press Institute thank you
thank you